We're making her strawberry lemon hand pies
from Maggie's Sweet Shoppe by Magnolia at the Silos.
So, all right, we've baked the pies,
they're looking gorgeous.
Yes, grab a spoon.
And you can get this little offset spatula.
And if you wanna get a spoon in your drawer.
Thank you.
This is the lemon glaze.
And it's basically just powdered sugar, some butter.
I really like this.
Yes, that size is good too.
Lemon zest, so I love, again, these are so organic,
they're handmade.
So the idea of it not being
this perfect like icing or frosting-
Thank God.
I like that it kinda
pours off the edges, so if you want, you can just,
you know, again, this is as much as you want.
But this is just powdered sugar,
fresh squeezed lemon juice, some lemon zest-
Zest makes
all the difference.
And butter, it really does.
Something about a fresh squeezed lemon.
And then you can just kinda move it around.
Do whatever you want.
It's like art class, you know?
If you were to take a girl's trip like,
you're with, you know-
I'm craving a girl's trip.
You're planning it,
what are you doing?
I told Chip
I need to go somewhere.
And I don't know yet,
I'm like trying to decide, is it beach?
Is it big city?
Is it middle of nowhere?
I'm going to Vegas with my girlfriend soon.
Okay, that sounds really fun.
They were like, "Where are we going?"
And you know, I literally go, "Vegas."
Vegas, let's do it.
We're going Vegas.
I love that. You ready?
Yes.
Okay, now cheers, my dear.
Cheers.
Oh.
Oh God.
Oh, that is flaky.
Flay flaky!
Thank God for that little egg and all that butter.
Oh my God, this is insane.
Do you like cumin?
Maybe a girls trip
is like, where can I just go eat all the things?
Again, Vegas.
That's probably
what I'm wanting in April.
I'm gonna go eat all the things,
and then just sit in the hotel bed and watch TV.
God these are so incredible.
Do they remind you of your childhood,
or no way, you see what I'm saying?
Is there something nostalgic about it?
No, craft service
reminds me of my childhood.
Okay. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
Where's that trail mix?
Joanna, when I say I love and admire you,
like I truly mean it.
It's hard to put into words
when you've like been alongside of someone,
you know, and you're just,
you've made me feel so much safer in the world.
You've inspired me.
You've made me feel like I can realize my dreams.
'Cause as women watching you grow,
and I don't think very gender-line-ish,
like I think I probably just as much like Chip
as I am like you, I'm androgynous,
but to see a working mom build the way that you've done,
and it has just been so beautiful watching your journey
as a consumer, then I'm sure I speak for,
you know gazillions of people, let alone women out there.
Thank you for saying that.
And if there's any way that this can connect with women
and hopefully empower, inspire them,
that's the greatest honor, that's the greatest gift.
Jo.
This has been so fun.
(upbeat music)